قالت وزاره الصحه في غزه ان الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي يحاصر مجمع الناصر الطبي في
مدينه خانيونس واكدت الوزاره ان مجمع ناصر
بحاجه ماسه للامدادات الطبيه والغذائيه
والوقود وان نحو 400 من مرضى الكلى لا
يستطيعون الوصول للمجمع المحاصر لتلقي
العلاج كما يواجه المصابون والمرضى
والحوامل مضاعفات خطيره نتيجه انعدام سبل
الوصول الى المست
المشفى قالت منظمه الصحه العالميه ان وضع
المستشفيات في خانيونس كارثي ولا يوصف
واعربت المنظمه عن قلقها ازاء تقارير تفيد
بفقد الاتصال بمستشفى الخير غربيه خانيونس
واحتجاز العاملين فيه واضافت المنظمه ان
الدخول الى مستشفى ناصر والخروج منه غير
ممكن بسبب القصف وهناك اعداد كبيره من
الجرحى داخله وقالت منظمه الصحه العالميه
ان سبعه من اصل 24 مستشفى تعمل بشكل جزئي
في شمال غزه وتعاني نقصا في الكوادر
والمستلزمات الطبيه
والوقود